[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARTER MORGAN: This episode
of the "Cloud Rolling Update"
is all about Google Container
Builder, a scalable solution
for building containers
on Google Cloud Platform.
I'm Carter Morgan, your
host for this series focused
on showing off features that
make delivering software
to and from Google
Cloud Platform
a great choice for
enterprise developers.
In every episode, I'll show
off cool technologies and tools
that I've gotten to learn from
much, much smarter people,
like Ahmet and
Kelsey in this case.
So while this episode is just
a quick overview of Container
Builder, you're going to want
to subscribe to the playlist
so you don't miss out on
the more advanced episodes.
And a quick aside before
we get started with GCB--
a container is just a way
to package and distribute
applications uniformly.
It does this by logically
separating an application
process from the environment
it's running inside of.
So inside this boundary,
parts of the file system,
the networking stack, and
other running processes
are hidden away from
the outside world.
To make sure that the
application is portable
and behaves the same
way anywhere it's run,
the application binary
is also bundled together
with its dependencies
and its environment.
So this resulting
application container
is fast to start
up and shut down.
It allows you to run your
application on any system that
can run containers, regardless
of the type of system
it was built on.
And it can be run next
to other containers
without knowing that
other applications are
running concurrently.
So aside from being able to
build an application once
and just know it's
going to behave
the exact same in
multiple environments,
the container also simplifies
application development
because two container
images can do things
like both receive traffic
on their local host port
8080 no problem.
So back to Container Builder.
What happens when you want
to build a container image?
A lot.
I like to simplify this process
by only using containers
to package and distribute
my application.
I don't use them to
build applications.
So keeping this in
mind, here are the steps
you need to run to
package and distribute
your application using Docker.
You need a few steps to
download and install Docker.
Then you create a
Docker file which
has instructions on how to
build the container image.
Then you need one or more steps
to build your application,
and then a step to build
and package your application
into a container, which
might download a base
image on your machine just
to upload the resulting
image into a registry where
other people can access it.
Oh, and that didn't
even talk about running
an instance of your container
or cleaning up the artifacts
that the build left behind.
Wouldn't it be great if there
was a managed service that
could speed up building
and distributing
your images by skipping
your workstation
altogether and doing the
heavy lifting in the cloud?
Well, Google Container
Builder is that service.
You can use it with your
favorite continuous integration
tools or build
systems, because it
uses tools you know and love,
like Docker files and GitHub,
so you don't have to learn
new tools to get started.
And on top of that, it's fast.
It has support for
custom build steps
which can be run concurrently.
And there's support for using
build triggers so that you can
create images automatically.
And all of this, all of this
comes with full integration
with Google Container Registry,
the same service that's
being used by Google Cloud
Functions, App Engine
Flex, and more.
So let's see this in action.
For example, if you
already have a Docker file,
you can just use it
like you normally would
to build a container image.
Here you can see we have
a standard Docker file.
We're going to build our
new application container
from the Alpine 3.1 base image.
Then we're going to add our
application binary, which
was built outside of Docker,
into our container's file
system.
And then we're going
to run our application
when the container starts up.
Now I can use the gcloud
container build submit command
to submit that build
to Container Builder.
From the output, you
can see that we just
built a container image without
it running on our laptop.
So let's explain
what just happened.
Since we already
had a Docker file,
we used it with the gcloud
tool that comes standard
with the Google Cloud SDK
to build a Docker image
and submit it to Container
Registry, Google's
private container
registry, all in one go.
Now, GCR works with
Docker images now,
but other image formats
are coming in the future.
It also lets you view
images by name or tag.
It allows you to create build
triggers that run and submit
new builds on pushes to code
in your source repository,
based on either your
branch name or your tag.
Once we ran that command, gcloud
packaged the source directory
and built a container
image in the cloud
by executing the
following steps.
We compressed the source
directory as a tarball.
We uploaded the source package
to Google Cloud Storage,
started a build request on
Google Cloud Container Builder,
streamed the build logs back to
the user's console, tagged the
build images, and then
pushed those images
to the GCR I/O registry.
And that's going to work for
any source repository directory
that has a Docker file.
So instead of saying docker
build and docker push,
well, you can just run gcloud
container build submit.
So to recap, GCB is
a fast and easy way
to create container
images in the cloud using
Google's infrastructure
that just plain works out
of the box with Docker files.
And if you want to customize
your build process or even run
parts of it
concurrently, well, GCB
provides a clean and
modular way to do that,
which we'll be talking
about it in a future video.
So for more information,
be sure to check out
the links from Ahmet and Kelsey
in the description below.
And subscribe to
the channel to learn
about more advanced features of
Google Cloud Container Builder,
like custom build pipelines.
Hey, thanks for watching.
Check out more great videos
from the cloud channel.
See you next time.